- Odaelys is gonna kick
us off with a question.
- Hi Viktor, a great question.
So my screens off 'cause
I'm feeding my son.
And so I really have a...
I think it's really
interesting how they have
Chinese medicine as one of the,
I guess, drugs that are given,
can you give an example
of what that would entail?
- So I'm not exactly sure
what the exact treatment was,
but the traditional
Chinese medicine are just
kind of things that in their culture
they consider to be medicinal.
And that patients are sometimes given
within Chinese hospitals.
So I'm not exactly sure
what they are specifically,
but that's something that they consider
to be medicinal.
- Yeah, I think that's really
interesting how like cultural
things play a role in like
medicines that people take
- Definitely, yeah.
- Yeah, I've also heard
that there's a lot of
sort of culturally related
diabetes treatments,
some things related to
turmeric and cinnamon
and things like that,
depending on which culture
you're coming from.
And speaking of region, I'm wondering,
do we know if the rate
of diabetes in the areas
where the study was performed
is at a different rate?
Or I guess, absolute number, even than,
what we are seeing in the United States?
'Cause diabetes is like
a huge disease here.
Is it as big in China?
- Sorry, did you say diabetes or COVID-19?
- Diabetes, diabetes.
- Diabetes, I think is more
prevalent in the United States
than in China.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
Just by...
- That's so interesting.
- [Viktor] Yeah when you
just for a population.
Yeah.
- Yeah, and so I wonder,
do you think that with,
if we now we're going
into speculation mode
with the ideas around,
so we have higher rates
of diabetes here in the United States.
And, we're not controlling COVID.
I mean, do you think that
the extensive death rate
that we're seeing here
compared to other places is,
in part because of some
of these comorbidities?
Or do you think it's more
related to mismanagement of,
social distancing or
testing or things like that?
- Or even health management?
- Yeah.
Yeah, absolutely, I think
it's definitely a combination
of all those factors.
But I definitely think, since we do have
a much greater incidence
of type 2 diabetes
specifically in the United States.
I do think the reason why
we're seeing so many deaths
and severe outcomes in the
United States is much higher.
Again, because
we have these communities
of color, which suffer
from type 2 diabetes at much higher rates
than many people in the world.
So that definitely could be a major factor
in why we're seeing so many
deaths and severe outcomes
in United States, yeah.
- Well, thanks.
- [Viktor] Yep.
- All right, so we have a question
from the audience.
So the question is, "Have these results
"informed early treatment of people,
"with type 2 diabetes or COVID-19,
"are they trying to get
blood glucose under control
"while treating for COVID-19?"
- I'm so sorry, could
you repeat that question?
- Yes, I think there are
wondering if the results
from the paper are informing
on any early treatments
for people with type 2 diabetes
and may become infected
with COVID-19.
That's the first part.
And the next part, are they
trying different things
like keeping your blood
glucose under control,
while treating for COVID-19
based on the results
of the paper?
- So, to address the
early treatments question,
from these results, I
mean, they are advocating
for basically, in general better control
of your blood glucose if you're diabetic,
just because COVID-19 is spreading through
all so quickly.
Sorry, could you repeat
the second question?
- Are they trying to get the
blood glucose under control
when people with type 2
diabetes get hospitalized
with COVID-19?
I don't know if that can
help in the moment or?
- Right, right, right, yeah.
So yeah, one major yeah,.
They did advocate for that, but again,
a really big limitation of the study
was that it was retrospective.
So they couldn't actually
follow if making their
blood glucose better,
would basically make their COVID
condition better over time.
So that's why doing
a prospective study
would really improve these results but
they do still say that they believe that
for a patient that's
hospitalized for COVID,
and that has type 2 diabetes,
one thing that definitely
could help would be to
manage their blood glucose
in real time.
- Oh, yeah, that's
probably pretty critical.
So what about,
diabetes has its own set
of comorbidities, right?
You have lots of heart
disease issues related to
the diabetic kind of milieu as they say.
- [Viktor] Absolutely.
- Were there any indication in terms of,
the presence of cardiovascular disease
or specific demographics,
like age or other types
of medications that they're
taking that maybe not related
to diabetes, was there any
indication that patients were,
I guess, was there any
summary of patient history
in how those factors could
have also impacted outcomes?
Or did the paper not go into that?
- So the paper did go into it.
But for the really big results,
were the graph that showed
the survival rates, they actually adjusted
for other comorbidities
like heart disease,
liver disease, so they tried
to only focus on diabetes.
Although they did mention
that those kinds of conditions
and comorbidities typically
come with type 2 diabetes
and are present in people
who do have type 2 diabetes
and they do say that these factors,
that can impact morbidity,
but that wasn't the focus
up there, obviously.
- Cool, thanks.
And that was from Peggy from Facebook.
So thank you for asking that question.
- And similar to the
the first question I asked,
are you aware of any measures
that China has implemented
in response to this paper,
in ways that they can promote
or better manage type 2
diabetes in a population?
- So I am not actually aware.
And this paper is pretty
recent, but I can imagine
that since they use all the
patients that have COVID-19
in this particular province
that they definitely are
probably using the results
from this paper to currently
treat individuals who have
COVID-19 and type 2 diabetes.
Although I'm not exactly sure.
- So we have a question from Susan,
who's one of our RockEDU moms.
So, hi, Susan.
Thank you for your question.
'Why was the group limited
to ages between 18 and 75?'
- So the reason they limited the cohorts
in the delineation of
age basically is because,
so first for individuals
who are above the age of 75,
these individuals typically
have a bunch of other
kind of conditions,
which could actually be
confounding factors for the study.
So those individuals were eliminated.
And then people who
were under the age of 18
could also have a lot of these factors.
But also, I would imagine that,
there must be some law for
individuals who are under
18 to not be consenting.
- Consenting.
- Yeah, I wonder we have in the
United States the age of 18,
as like the sort of that barrier
between childhood and adult
is that a universal age across the world?
That's something I
actually I wonder about.
- I think it's different, in
some places I think it's 16.
- [Viktor] Yeah.
- In some countries.
- Okay, interesting.
- Yeah.
- So I wonder what it is in China.
I'm ignorant when it comes to
that stuff, so I apologize.
- Yeah, I actually, I'm not sure either,
but I think the main reason
is because these ages could
represent confounding factors
in the analysis of the data.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Good point.
Another question, do you
think or is there a difference
in the lungs of people
with type 2 diabetes?
I think this is pointing
at the fact that COVID-19
seem to inflict on lung
cells more than other cells
in the body.
- Yeah, so they actually did
talk a little bit about this,
in the paper, saying that individuals
who have really advanced type 2 diabetes,
particularly the individuals who have
the poorly controlled blood
glucose often have damage in
their vascular systems as
well as in their related
lung systems, so the paper
does mention that they think
that's actually where the comorbidity
for the respiratory illness
comes from is the degradation
of vascular as well as respiratory systems
as a result of diabetes.
- So we have a question from Chloe,
who was d4p fellow,
one, three sessions ago,
if you're including this one.
So welcome back, Chloe,
thank you for joining.
The question is, did all type
2 diabetic patients receive
the same standard care
for COVID-19, and if not
did the survival analysis
showing differences between
the well and control
patients account for that?
- So the treatment was very uniform
for just COVID-19 patients in general,
but the differences came
when the patients had
severe outcomes.
So if, for example, they
had the like ARDS syndrome,
which was the acute
respiratory distress syndrome,
then they of course had to
have different treatments
than did other patients.
What they did was they didn't compare
directly patients who
basically didn't have
the same treatments.
So they delineated it in that way to
remove that as like a confounding factor.
Of course, you can't remove all factors
that confound the analysis,
but I think they try
their best in that regard.
- Great, and question from Mackenzie.
So can you talk more about
why poor BG, blood glucose,
control exasperates COVID-19
from physiology perspective?
- Yeah, so they're really
a plethora of reasons.
So when you have a really
poorly controlled blood glucose,
it means that you're either
not getting enough insulin
or your condition is
maybe really advanced.
So in this case, a few
things can be happening.
So as a result of all the
glucose in your blood again,
it can cause a lot of damage
to your vasculature, it can
cause damage to your nerves,
it can cause a bunch of
damage to multiple organs.
And then, of course,
since the cells ain't
getting enough glucose
there can be, a huge, chemical cascade,
where a bunch of issues
can occur just because
a lot of processes that
typically will be occurring
or won't be occurring.
So then as a result of all this,
a bunch of different diseases
can manifest actually
from type 2 diabetes like I mentioned,
like liver disease, kidney
disease and stuff like that.
And then what happens then is
a bunch of things happen, but then
your immune system can also
really become compromised.
And we know that from that
you can have really severe
outcomes from COVID-19.
Yeah, and in general, the answer is,
there's a lot of reasons.
But I think the main
reason is just because
your systems basically just start failing
and then your immune
system is compromised,
and then you're just more susceptible to
severe outcomes through COVID.
- And I think
- I think,
go ahead.
- Along those lines,
do you think medication
might have anything to do with that?
Like so people with type 2
diabetes are taking medications
that might alter certain
other aspects in the body?
- Yeah, I definitely think
that is a factor for sure.
However, I'm not really exactly sure about
the specifics, although
the study did show that,
even though the poorly
controlled blood glucose group,
were given more medications,
they did survive less than the well-controlled group
- I think we're gonna end
with one last question from Aditi.
Thank you for joining us, once again.
So happy to have you back with us.
I think you might have the
frequent flyer card for d4p
at this point in time.
I think one day maybe we'll
get you a free coffee out it
for ice cream.
(chuckling)
So her question is, since the study
and others concerning COVID-19
have been performed in China,
how are the results or
implications being interpreted
in other nations and are
other nations taking actions
to specifically address populations
with type 2 diabetes?
- Yeah, so, since the study
was performed in China,
obviously there are
certain cultural factors
and certain community factors,
which could definitely affect
the results.
But in general, I think, since
the study was so rigorous
and it was performed on
such a humongous cohort,
again it was like 7000 total patients,
I think it's being interpreted
pretty generally all over the world,
although again, as I
mentioned certain communities,
like communities of color,
which disproportionately
are affected by both type
2 diabetes as well as COVID
may have unique factors which
affects their comorbidities.
So certain aspects of
the study may not apply
to those communities.
But I do believe that
similar studies like these
are being performed
in the United States, in
these particular communities
and all around the world.
- Yeah, I think it's really
interesting when you mentioned,
it's not really having type 2 diabetes,
but whether or not it's been well managed.
Some of the issue here or some
of those communities is that
access to healthcare is a big thing.
- Absolutely.
- Getting the medication to control
can definitely impact that.
- [Viktor] Yeah.
- Or like the price of
insulin, here in America,
it's just out of control.
- [Viktor] Absolutely yeah.
- And so all of these things I'm sure
this is gonna be a very messy data set
coming out in the United States, I think.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- When we look at this
type of data for us.
- [Viktor] Yeah.
- That's another reason
why the American system
needs an overhaul.
- Right, right.
Yeah, and I think the
data in the United States
is gonna be so so high
dimensional, because there's just
so many factors, social,
economic, biological obviously,
that play into this issue.
So I think it's gonna take a
lot of a really good analysis
to figure out what the
exact causes really are.
- Yeah, I think makes
the data really messy.
And I'm thinking about a time I went
to an international
conference and a lot of their,
researchers, don't even ask or mention
socioeconomic status,
'cause that's not an issue
in their country.
- Yeah.
(chuckling)
- It really highlights,
I think, the system in the
United States especially.
- But I actually don't
think socioeconomic,
I think socioeconomics is an
issue in every single country,
it's that there are cultures
that are more comfortable
ignoring it than others.
And I think United States
definitely falls into that.
We're very uncomfortable talking about it.
- [Viktor] Definitely yeah.
- This is, everybody likes to be
in their little bubble of privilege.
And, I think we really need
to start dismantling that.
- Definitely.
And addressing the issues at hand.
- Yeah, yeah, and I think
Leanne mentions we all agree
that do this in type 2
diabetes as a priority
of course it's a priority for everybody.
This is definitely one of the big--
This is a pandemic just
in a different way.
You know?
- Absolutely yeah.